hey
everyone this is Brian Green coming to
you live from New York City and today
our topic is cosmology really trying to
understand the history of the universe
how we went from some hot beginning to
the universe that we currently witness
through powerful telescopic observations
and we will then turn in our
conversation which will be with sir
Martin Reese to perhaps some of the
challenges that we as a species face
some of the opportunities that we have
going forward and just by 30 second
preamble to part of the motivation for
this conversation at least from from my
point of view look the material is
interesting in its own right you don't
need to motivate any conversation about
the history of the universe after all
but there have been some interesting
articles of late partly inspired by data
from the James web space telescope which
and again some of these articles were
written by people I know friends of mine
people I I I respect but some of the
Articles seem to suggest that the
observations that we already have in
hand the data that we have are
suggesting that our understanding of
cosmology is broken or that we don't
really understand anything about what
happened in the distant past it's not
conforming with Theory observation
Theory at odds and look it's always
exciting when they're new observations
that make us think harder about things
but there have been so many hard one
battles spectacular achievements in the
arena of
cosmology and I sort of hate the idea
that somehow there's a sense that maybe
we got it all wrong because nothing
really could be farther from the truth
at least based on the observ ations that
we currently have I'm not saying that a
thousand years from now what we say
today is going to be still chiseled in
readable Stone but certainly nothing
that's happened so far with the James
web Space Telescope has really
invalidated our understanding of
cosmology and joining me to discuss
these ideas will be in just a moment
I'll bring him in as Sir Martin Ree
who's really one of the the world's
great cosmologists astrophysicists had
made so many
pivotal contributions to to cosmology to
Black Hole to our understanding of
Galactic structure he was a past
president of the Royal Society master of
Trinity College he is currently the UK's
astronomer Royal and so it does give me
great pleasure to bring in my colleague
and friend sir Martin Ree so Martin oh
there he is hey Martin how are you doing
fine great to be with you you know I
have to tell you oftentimes when we do
these conversations we instru instruct
the person I'm talking to to have a nice
white background a nice sheet or
something just so that it isn't
distracting you've got like the most
beautiful background that that we have
ever seen so uh so it's wonderful to
have you but it's also wonderful to have
your background as well where you where
are you at the moment well I'm in the uh
space above my garage which is really my
big study and you see books around there
but it's a it's a great place to have
these events I would I I I almost
curious to ask you to take your camera
and give us a tour of the rest of your
establishment out there but that would
take us a little too far too far our
field but maybe we should all get your
Architects contact information but then
again that's for a separate conversation
but um you know as I said there's been
some interesting work with the James web
Space Telescope and there was this
article at least one that I'm aware of
in the New York Times that gives the
impression that cosmology
is broken based upon the new
observations and so where do where do
you come down on
that well I'm very critical of that
article it made a number of Highly
misleading statements but I think what
happens in science as you alluded to in
your introduction is that we make
advances and then Mysteries at the
boundary of our knowledge come into a
sharper Focus so always there are things
that are uncertain um but um my take on
cosmology now and I can try and justify
that is that we got a basic outline of
what happened back to when Universe was
about a microsc
old
but what happened before that in the
first tiny tiny fraction of a second is
very important and I guess we come to
that but the um James web telescope was
really looking back to when the universe
was a few hundred million years old a
few percent of its present age and it's
been important in understanding the way
galaxies formed because we obviously
know in the very early Universe they
didn't exist and we want to understand
how the universe gradually um
agglomerates its content into galaxies
and um we found that because the James
web telescope can look back further in
the past further out into space um it's
able to look for Galaxies which are
close to their formation and there are
certainly some surprises um but I think
uh nothing that is causing any
fundamental problems because um one
thing which is crucial in understanding
G information is that we
have a clear agreement among all
cosmologists almost that there is dark
matter some kind of swarm of particles
we don't know what they are but they
contribute about five times as much mass
material as the ordinary atoms and so
that therefore means that what really
happens is that as the universe expands
the um dark matter agglomerates and then
we understand that and there simulations
which match that very well indeed but
then when the gas Falls in and starts
turning into stars and black holes
things get very complicated yeah and
there are some surprises but that's very
complicated and we have no reason to
expect that it would physic and so I
think we've learned some surprising
things and it's going to help us to
understand them better but I don't think
it overturns anything we already knew
yeah so I mean again as people have uh
no doubt read about the data the
observations are suggesting that those
early galaxies may be brighter and more
massive than perhaps we initially
thought but as you're rightly pointing
out there's so much detailed
astrophysics that goes into the
formation of a galaxy that yeah maybe
the data is going to help sharpen our
understanding of those processes and it
will be different because the the
density of anything collapses is much
higher if collapses early on than now
and um the universe is hotter so the way
gas fragment into the stars is going to
be different and so one thing that's
probably happening is that the average
mass and brightest of the stars that
form then is higher than those that
formed today and that means that a
galaxy of given mass is be brighter and
black holes can grow very quickly Etc so
I think there's a lot to understand and
um we've only had the first bit of data
but lots more is coming in and I think
we will get a much clearer picture when
we've got more data yeah no I I
absolutely agree and so just to give
people a sense of of how really
spectacular it is that here we are these
little puny human beings crawling around
on this rock
and orbit around an ordinary star that
we've been able to figure out back to
these early moments the history of the
universe and the physics that guided the
unfolding I thought it would be
worthwhile to just do a a brief walk
through the key moments that have led to
the current standard model of cosmology
the Lambda CDM model cosmology so if
you'll play along with me and we can
just sort of go through this I think
it'll really give people a sense of the
stunning achievement that we've gotten
to so far where would you pick up the
story I was going to take us all the way
back to George lra is that is that a
original place to
begin even further but uh we we knew
since the 1920s this our Milky Way was
one of galaxies galaxies are the main
features of the Universe on a large
scale and those galaxies are moving away
from each other as though everything was
crushed close together in the past and
that's been known since the
1950s although the evidence was rather
weak back then and it's got much
stronger um what we don't know of course
is what happened very early on when
things were far away um and we're seeing
them in the past um and what we'd like
to do is to look far enough out in space
to actually see when galaxies were much
younger and when Universe was more
compressed more it is now and that's
been an ongoing project in the
1960s um two things happen first it
became possible to observe galaxies far
enough away that we could see they were
different and that was important because
that showed the universe wasn't in a
steady state yeah and you mentioned lra
but his rival was Fred Hy um one of my
mentors and predecessors who thought the
universe had been there from Everlasting
to Everlasting always in the same St
State expanding but new galaxies forming
and um that was refuted firstly by
seeing that distant galaxies weren't
like nearby ones but then more
convincingly in
1964 when the so-called um uh um Echoes
of creation were found the microwave
background radiation filling all of
space which is the relic of the
universe's hot dense beginning that
radiation filled the universe it's got
nowhere else to go and it's started off
very hot so everything was like the
inside of a star and then it cooled and
separated out from the the matter but is
still around and it raises the
temperature of the universe to nearly 3
degrees above absolute zero which isn't
much but it's a relic of the hot
Afterglow of the early universe so that
was a big advance in the
1960s but before you go on from there
Martin so you mentioned you know Fred Hy
as being a dominant figure at that time
and of course I think as many in our
audience know and you made reference to
his view with the so-called steady state
cosmology right as you say the universe
has always been or always would be here
that was also a view that until
1930 Albert Einstein more or less held
right I think many people had that
perspective and so I guess the first
evidence was Edwin Hubble showing that
what now we recognize as galaxies were
all rushing away from us giving rise to
the expanding universe and that was an
important moment but my question to you
is since you you were around with hoil
at the time when the microwave
background radiation that I think we had
a picture of before we can bring it back
up when the microwave backround
radiation was discovered this heat left
over some hot beginning did that
convince Fred Hoy or was they trying to
find ways of explaining that too within
a universe that had always existed yes
um no he never really accepted the Big
Bang at all um and uh even to his dying
day he had very complicated ways of uh
of getting the observations but I think
he's lost interest and became rather out
of touch in his later years doing other
or Ecentric things as some old
scientists do um but um he he never
really accepted it but most people uh
when there was this evidence of the uh
uh radiation filling the universe they
believed that it couldn't be explained
other than by a um assumption that the
Universe do hot and dense um and this
radiation to First approximation comes
from all directions um the picture you
were just showing of course was a later
one because when people um were able to
study the um uh background intensity
coming from different directions they
discovered that it wasn't quite the same
temperature everywhere there were some
slightly hotter regions in average some
slightly cooler ones and this picture is
a projection of the um the whole Sky
rather like you see maps of the Earth in
this projection um and this is look at
the sky uh but the fluctuations show
shown here the uh the red bits are the
hot bits and the blue bits or the cold
bits but there are these irregularities
they're very small
the temperature varies by about one part
at 100,000 between the red and the blue
between red and blue yes so everything
was fairly smooth and some was
just slightly overdense um and um some
slightly underdense but the important
point is that this radiation is coming
from very very far away much further
away than the first galaxies so we're
looking back to when the universe was
about 13,000 of his present age and the
important thing which we've come to
understand fairly well is that if you
put into your computer conditions in the
early Universe rather like we get it
from this picture where there are some
reason a little bit hotter and denser
than others and then run it forward then
as Universe expands the slightly
overdense bits lag behind more and more
because of the excess gravity and the
density contrast grow and eventually
they separate out and one of the great
achievement
[Music]
which makes most of us convinced that
there's something in this model is that
um if you start off with what the
universe was like at this early time and
compute forward you get something which
is rather like the present universe so
as far as we can J there a lot of
uncertainties of course but the broad
outline fits very well with the present
Universe um and essentially because the
um dark material has clumped and the gas
has fallen into it to make Stars Etc so
we have a direct link between the
universe when it was
um about 1 30,000 of his present age and
the present and um the James Webb
Telescope is now filling in the gaps
because that's looking at the time when
the universe was a few percent of its
present age but also in fact um even
since the 1960s we've had other quite
different evidence for um the Mar before
we go into the other evidence which I'd
love to get to I just want to nail this
one just to be absolutely certain so
this photograph is basically as you say
130,000 the current age of the universe
about 380,000 years after what we
believe to be the beginning so just so
people completely get it the tiny
temperature differences the red and the
blue which differ by as you say one part
and say
100,000 those tiny temperature
differences are the seeds for the
formation of structure in the universe
because those little tiny differences
get Amplified over the course of cosmic
history giving rise to yet more
differences between places of the
universe galaxies versus not galaxies
and so forth so that picture is the
seeds of everything that we now witness
in the heavens yeah yes and there's a
lot of detail because you can analyze
the um that picture and look at the uh
as it's like the ocean you can look at
the amplitude of ways of different way
wavelength you know and and so we've got
a lot of detail and that detail is fed
into the computer and that fits a lot of
the details now we're showing a little
picture of that right now so there's the
the theoretical curve you know that
comes from our calculations and there
are the observations which uh again
people don't have to know the details of
what we're seeing here but look at that
spectacular agreement between
mathematics the solid curve and
observations the yellow dots I mean if
that doesn't convince you that there's
something deep here I don't know what
would yes and I think that's one of the
most remarkable diagrams in the whole of
physical sciences I do this was more as
predicted um and uh from this picture
you can infer um the Scale of the
Universe and the proportions of ordinary
matter and dark matter and the the ones
you get by fitting that diagram agree
with what we observe it discrepancies
about 5% in many ways and and many
things we don't understand like Star
formation but this is a I think
spectacular Triumph and with which means
that we should take this very seriously
and um just to go back to Hil um in the
1960s um uh he was an expert on um uh
nuclear physics and indeed his great his
greatest scientific achievement was in
1950s when he and three colleagues um
Fowler Jeffy and Mar Burbage they uh got
uh a picture of how all the chemical
elements were made in Stars starting
with hydrogen and helium and why there's
lots of um carbon oxygen not much
uranium Etc that's a great achievement
which they did but oil when the Big Bang
was discovered with two other with
Fowler and another collaborator Wagoner
they calculated what nuclear reactions
would occur during the early stages when
the entire universe was as hot as a
center of the star which is in fact the
first few minutes of the universe and
they calculated all would emerge from
The Big Bang as it cooled down due to
these reactions was um about 25%
helium nearly all the rest
hydrogen um bit of lithium but no
elements uh heavier than that and there
again this fit with observations the
percentage of helium in gas's objects is
known very well so again we've got
confidence in tracing back to when the
universe was a a few minutes old and of
course um we've got to bear in mind the
philosophical uh inference that the laws
of nature are pretty Universal they're
Universal in all the huge volume we can
study with our telescopes I mean if it
if the atoms in distant galaxies behave
differently from those near to us if we
had a sort of anarchic universe we' make
no progress but to the prison we know to
the Precision we know um the um atoms um
were the same um when the universe was a
few seconds old as they are now and the
same does that surprise you Martin that
the universe is in some sense that
simple that what we see here is more or
less what we see there um well I think
it initially it's surprising of course
um uh as we develop theories it becomes
possible to understand natural reasons
why that should be so but I think think
it is aori surprising that the universe
doesn't display more variety we we know
it does in many other ways but the the
basic physical laws the strength of
gravity uh the electric forces the
nuclear forces Etc they do seem to be
the same and the evidence for that is is
pretty good in that you can take the
spectrum of the light from a distant
Galaxy and um from the spectral details
you can infer that the electrons running
around the atoms had the same mass with
high Precision back then as now in fact
who was it that said that one thing will
never figure out is what the distant
stars are made of someone I someone
famous said that I can't remember who it
was uh was
it yes um I'm having a senior moment but
comp maybe I I don't yes was in the in
the 1840s um and um he was disproved um
within about 30 or 40 years um when um
bunson and Higgins and others um took
the spectrum of the light from nearby
stars and nebuli and they showed that um
the stars were made of the same stuff as
as the earth I mean there was the old
idea that there were the the four
elements earth air far and water but
that the the uh Heavens were a separate
quintessence of fifth elements um but
the idea the stars were made of the same
stuff as the Earth was uh proved
actually not really until the 1850s or
so right so so microwave background
radiation understanding between and
agreement between Theory and observation
the formation of
nuclei wonderful agreement between
Theory and observations all of this is
starting to feel you know pretty good
about understanding How the Universe has
evolved for at least a substantial
window of cosmological History yes there
is still there's still mysteries in
there maybe we should just quickly call
them out because you've made reference
to Dark Matter a few times yes um well
of course I should mention that some
people are puzzled by the idea of D
matter but there's no reason why
everything in the universe should shine
there all kinds of exist we don't know
which ones they are which would act like
a swarm of particles and uh it turns out
that to fit all this data you need to
Suppose there about five times as much
stuff in that form as is ordinary matter
but I think um uh what what you're
saying has the implication of course
that as we have understood all this it
brings into sharper Focus question we
don't understand and of course the most
obvious ones are why is the universe
expanding The Way It Is Why does it have
those ingredients um and um uh what will
be its its Fai
Etc and um in particular a puzzle is why
the universe is um apart from these
fluctuations why is it so uniform yeah
if you look as far as we can in One
Direction then the opposite direction it
looks more or less the same and and and
that's um that actually is a very big
puzzle if one thinks more deeply about
it and so those are the kind of things
which must be imprinted at some earlier
stage yeah and um over the last 40 years
there's been a huge as you know
theoretical work um on what the answer
is but I think it's important to
distinguish what I've said up till now
which is about uh when the contents of
the universe behave according to laws
that we understand and in conditions
that we can simulate in the lab and
implication inferences about the very
very early Universe yeah when condition
conditions are far far different far
denser far hotter that we could ever
achieve in the lab so the science is
intrinsically far more speculative um
but of course um there have been many
many ideas and you've written a book
about all this stuff uh about what
happen early on but just to put it in
perspective um if you take the presently
observable universe out to the limits of
what the James web telescope can see
then if we extrapolate back to um when
the universe was about a mill
old that would be shrunk down to the
size of our solar system now why do I
take a millisecond that's the time um
when the particles in the universe had
energies above which we are uncertain
about the physics yeah how okay so we
know that but in order to answer these
fundamental questions why is universe
expanding um why is it so uniform then
uh there's a widespread consensus we've
got to go back much much further still
right how much very much because we've
got to back go back to a time when the
entire universe was compressed not
merely to the size of our solar system
but to the size of a tennis ball or
baseball if you prefer but a huge
increase in in the density and so and
this is of course
um physical regime wears a huge amount
of theory String Theory uh Etc uh which
unifies gravity with the micop physical
forces and that that theory um is needed
um to um understand what's going on back
there but of course as you know uh we
don't know which if any of those
theories of the extreme conditions which
unify gravity is a correct Theory um and
uh and so um although there's been a
important idea called the inflationary
idea which suggests that the Universe
went through a phase when it expanded
very very fast then slowed down so so
Martin I'd love to come to inflation
just a moment but I do want to ask you
one thing so you're absolutely right of
course if we want to probe the physics
of the very early Universe we are facing
the challenge that there's a limit to
what we can do in the laboratory and and
do those studies right here but many
people thought and I certainly was among
them and I wonder where used I had
thought that the Large Hadron Collider
would very likely discover the dark
matter I pretty much thought it was a
foregone conclusion that the Dark Matter
would be one of these super symmetric
particles one of these particles that
naturally come out of these beyond the
standard model of particle physics
theories and yet that has has not
happened um where where did you think
that there was a likelihood that we'd
find the the dark matter at the at the
collider um well I mean um I'm not an
expert but there was there was a hope
obviously but I don't think anyone
should be too surprised that we didn't
find it because there are at least um a
factor of many billions between the
energy you conceive in the um colliders
and the energy uh where you want some of
these processes to occur in the early
Universe which lay lay down so and there
are other kinds of particles called
axons and many others and many we
haven't thought of which could exist so
um it was it's been dis pointing that
the collider at CERN hasn't found more
particles beyond the higs um but I don't
think that's um something which should
destroy our belief in some kind of dark
matter although we still love to know
what it is and of course uh that's
something which is a challenge to
theorists just as the gross popul of the
universe are um and uh and of course the
the main aim is to try and unify gravity
with the micro iCal forces which we have
to do when everything gets gets so dense
that the quantum uncertainty would
affect even a black
hole uh but but I think um and the is
this idea of inflation which does um
understand explained by the universe
could have gone through a rapid phase um
and this was um dis discovered or first
put forward by some people particularly
Alan goth um and that was 40 years ago
and I think the reason we being
pessimistic about what's happened since
then because there's been a huge Barack
range of ideas as you know very well um
variance of inflation and physics back
at Early Times um but nothing which um
uh is part of a consensus and no way in
which any of these
theories connect with the low energy
world yeah if we had these theories and
you could calculate to and come out with
the mass of the electron correct or
something like that you know there's
something in it but we haven't got any
progress yet in connecting uh any of
these theories which are crucial to
validate before we can talk about the
early Universe with confidence uh and
the low Universe we inhabit and this is
depressing because given the analogy um
I learned about quantum theory in the
1960s and that theory was 40 years old
schinger and Heisenberg in the 1920s um
and uh the idea of inflation and Alan
goth that's as far in the past for
present day students as Heisenberg and
short go were for us that's a scary way
of putting it yes and frankly the
progress made since go in that area is
minimal compared to the progress made in
applying quantum theory in the 40 years
after yeah um so that's just a reason
for slight disappointment right about
the race of progress but it's a huge
challenge of course to have a theory
with which goes so many PS of 10 beyond
what we can observe or test directly in
the lab so let's I I want to spend a
couple minutes on in inflation but again
as you have done very carefully in this
conversation and I want to come back to
it when we talk about the standard model
of cosmology we're not talking about
these more speculative ideas that we're
about to talk about we're talking about
the very ideas that allowed us to make
predictions about the microwave
background radiation make predictions
about the abundances of various nuclei
and the agreement again between Theory
and observation is spectacular so we're
in really strong shape with our
understanding cosmology that's all all
happened within the last 40 years or
last 20 years even yeah and so now when
we go a little further as you're saying
as people have tried to do like Alan
goth and Andre Lind and Paul steinhardt
and of course many others they were
trying to go beyond our understanding
because that's what we do we don't just
stop when we have success we try to go
forward and one of the questions that
they sought to address was what started
the expansion in the first place and
they realize there's this beautiful
piece of physics that Einstein gave us
with his general theory of relativity
that if a little region of space gets
filled uniformly with an energy as
opposed to a clumpy piece of matter like
a star or a planet a uniformly spread
energy can give rise to a repulsive
gravity it infuses space with his
outward push that that could have been
the bang in the Big Bang and so started
the inflationary Theory which has
occupied as you've noted many theorists
and and observers and astronomers and
physicists for 40 years there's
now some grumblings of foot even by say
Paul steinhardt one of the people who
started the inflationary theory that
maybe that's not the right Next Step In
cosmology and he's put forward these
ideas of a of a cyclic Universe to take
the place of the inflationary one does
that resonate with you at all well I
think we should be openminded about what
happened um but in any any case it
involves um some kind of Uncertain
physics yeah the universe bounced that
involves uncertain physics um and and
the main point is to get causal contact
to to understand how the different part
our fent universe managed to synchronize
themselves yeah way and and so those are
the challenges which he would accept and
we just don't yet have a decent Theory I
mean inflation may not be the the right
answer and of course String Theory may
be the wrong Theory the L font of
gravity may be all that um so we just we
just don't know and of course maybe we
shouldn't be too depressed or surprised
because of course um it's
a the simple things have been done and
it may take a long time before we have
such a theory um uh but of course we
also if I can digress this for a moment
it could be that one of the one of your
string theories is correct um but it
could be that um the maths of this
10-dimensional geometry is just too hard
for any human to do in their lifetime
and so we may and this is interesting um
it may be that AI can save us it could
be that um
is one of these theories and um AI given
the conditions can because it thinks
much faster than we can it can actually
turn away and um if it comes up with the
mass of the electron bits of the
standard model or something like that
then we will know that it's got some
validity um even though we may not
actually understand it we may never have
the AA Insight because it may be beyond
our competence to understand it but of
course that would be important because
um if we have evidence that a
theory um is validated and that theory
can be applied to the very early
Universe we could then take something
like inflation more seriously and then
start discussing what the early univ is
like did it bounce are that many big
Banks not one in all those questions
because the reason we can't do more than
speculate about those is we don't know
the relevant physics but what do we do
at that stage I mean let's imagine that
we do have an AI system that you know it
had look what is our brain our brain is
a pattern recognition machine right so
it looks out into the world and it tries
to find patterns it encapsulates those
patterns in mathematical equations and
then it finds patterns within the
patterns and that's the way we make
progress and find coherence AI is really
good at finding patterns right we've all
seen it with like chat GPT you allow the
system to read the entire inter interet
and then in the patterns of patterns and
patterns of words it's there there's
enough in there that it can start to
write poetry and and and and come up
with Pros that's that's believable so if
an AI system was to use that pattern
recognition capacity to be able to
answer things that we can't answer and
like you say comes up with the mass of
the electron or How the Universe began
if we can't grasp it Beyond simply
seeing the result we can't see the inner
workings the step by step that at least
in Broad brush takes you to the answer
what do we do with that answer it's like
it's being handed to us from on high
like like a religious text what what do
we do with that information yes yes um
well I think what you say would be true
if we couldn't understand any of it but
if we just can't understand the
intermediate workings we might still uh
be able to uh understand at least
conceive of a theory like one of
the inputs into the into Linda's theory
for instance um if we knew that the uh
physics that he put into his vers of
inflation was correct but you see Martin
even if you talk to even if you talk to
AI people right now with the large
language models most of them will say we
don't really understand how it's able to
accomplish what it accomplishes yes in
Broad brush we understand what networks
are we understand the Transformer
architecture we understand the inner
working sort of but would we have
anticipated that it could do what it's
doing it's mind-blowing even to them
would that be a satisfying place if
that's the level of our understanding of
the mass of the electron or the
expansion rate of the Universe um well
no we like better but I think there are
intermediate cases I mean let's let's
say protein
folding where um as you know the
yes the alpha go plus has done far
better than humans in in doing that um
uh and we don't quite know how it does
it but nonetheless we get the results
and we can use them and so the
optimistic uh version of what I'm saying
would be that we don't understand the
workings but we get a theory uh which we
we can understand and um and we may have
the equation we could put into some
particular version of inflation or
something like that and then uh it would
make sense to um ask does that
particular version lead to a universe do
expands the way ours does uh does it
lead to many Big Bangs rather than one
the soal Eternal inflation Multiverse
model um would all those universities be
governed by the same microphysics all
those questions those are the ones we'd
like to answer and the point is that
they're now pure speculation if you
don't know the underlying physics that
set them up whereas if we did have a
theory that we could write down which
applied back then uh then we would take
its consequences seriously just as we
take cons seriously the um calculations
by hoil and others of the um helium
production men univ second old because
we can test those theories in the lab
yeah uh and would you consider that a
satisfying endgame to all the
questioning that we as a species have
been undertaking for all of the years
when we could turn our heads and look
skyward well I mean it be better if we
had more brain could understand it more
but why should you expect this I mean I
I I mean I go further and say that um it
may well be the case that uh there are
deep aspects of physical reality which
are just beyond the human brain
completely just as Quantum here is
beyond a monkey so I think we got got to
accept that there are many things but of
course um
this is not something which should
surprise us though it may depress us um
and uh of course we then need to realize
that we are not the culmination of
evolution maybe not even halfway stage
and so there's no biic reason why we
should be able to understand all these
things and of course um many things in
structure of the brain and biology um
may be even harder for us to fully
conceptualize than the things we've been
talking about no I fully agree with you
I mean after all our brains evolved
under the pressures of survival and
among those pressures was not trying to
understand the mass of the electron it
was trying to understand how to get the
next meal how to build a shelter how to
procreate you know and so forth so yeah
so it is rather remarkable that we have
managed to understand the mic microw
world and the cosmos even though um our
brains haven't changed much since our
ancestors African savanas and just World
exactly so you you made mention that
maybe the AI system would not only find
the mass of the electron but establish
that we're one of many universes right
this idea of a Multiverse which is
something that has been kicked around
for a long time in in physics uh String
Theory suggests that as a possibility
because there are many solutions to the
fundamental equations the theory each
looks different from the others each
seems to be a potentially sensible
Universe inflationary cosmology gives
its own version because the outward push
of that fuel that gives the repulsive
gravity can happen multiple times maybe
infinitely many times giving rise to
bang after bang after bang so this is a
highly controversial subject that uh
people have not been arguing directly
about as much in the last few years I
think it's sort of settled down a little
bit to the people who like the
Multiverse and those who don't we all
sort of
coexist where do you stand right now on
the issue of a Multiverse well I think
we we should be open minded we have no
idea whether it exists or not yeah and
we won't have any firm idea until we uh
we do get the physics of the ultra early
Universe which you may never get but but
um we we certainly can't make any firm
evidence but but if we did have um
physics which uh
led to a model of
inflation like lindes which does lead to
this then I think we should um uh take
the um uh idea of the Multiverse
seriously we shouldn't just say it's
metaphysics it's speculative science now
but it would be sence and it's a mistake
to think that we have to be able to
observe and test all the consequences of
the theory um if you have a theory that
is established battle tested in other
ways then we take seriously the um
implications Mak when we can't say
Einstein's theory we um believe what he
says about the inside of black holes to
some extent where we can't observe
because we got pretty good evidence that
uh relativity Works outside black holes
and in many other places so I think um
at the moment it's completely
speculative and I think it's absurd to
have strong views Pro or con is not
absurd and um uh I think just to make
two more points one is if it's it's true
uh then it'll be a a fourth and most
exciting capern
Revolution the sun was not the sentor
then the Galaxy wasn't Etc and uh our
observable universe will will not be the
entire part of reality um and so there
would be lots and lots of space indeed
most of space which is in principle not
observable by us but we can defer it
there and indeed that's probably true
even if there's only one Universe
because I think most um there is the
sort of horizon around us which is
determined by how far light been able to
get since the Big Bang crudely speaking
and um but I think no one thinks that
the galaxies stop Beyond there
then since the universe is so smooth
across from that side to that side then
almost certainly goes on in any Theory
quite a bit further and um so the
galaxies out there that we can never see
and if they acceleration continues we
never see so I think even conservative
astronomers are prepared to accept that
there are galaxies parts of physical
reality which you can never in principle
observe yeah and it's not a big step
from that to say that some of these may
be the aftermath of other Big Bangs not
ours and then of course what's
interesting as you mentioned already is
whether if there are other Big Bangs
will their aftermaths be all governed by
the same microphysics or could there be
some where gravity stronger or weaker
sure and it's rather fun to explore
these counterfactual universes yeah no
and the point you make is a good one
that I don't know that everybody fully
appreciates which is we currently see
that the expansion of space is
accelerating and that establishes that
there are Realms that are simply too far
away to ever see if the acceleration
continues because the ever widening Gap
is simply widening too fast for light to
be able to Traverse the separation
between us so we already invoke Realms
that we can't see we can't directly
access and so if a Multiverse does that
too it doesn't fall outside of the
normal lexicon the normal collection of
ideas that we're willing to entertain
even in today's Cutting Edge theories so
that's certainly the case um but you
mentioned capern Revolution which is a
natural segue to the possibility of
other life out there in the universe
that would be a pretty significant
contributor to a cernic revolution not
only are we not the center we're not the
only life out there in the universe you
know I think most people are comfortable
with the idea that look life didn't take
all that long on geological time scales
to take hold here on planet Earth so
maybe it's not that hard for for life to
get started do you think that reasoning
is too glib I mean obviously having one
more example would be really important
but where do you come down yes yes no I
think this is a case when we must be
open-minded I mean it's logically
possible that life is unique thing that
only happened here most people say it's
unlikely and of course uh there is uh um
now serious effort
in understanding or's life I mean in the
past it was put in the as it were two
difficult box is experiment by Miller
and Yuri 60 years ago um to far Sparks
through amino acids and things and no
one did anymore to follow that up they
thought was too hard whereas now they
were very serious people there some my
colleagues in Cambridge and many others
you're trying to make life in a test
tube in the laboratory for SC to
understand what what causes transition
from complex biochemistry to some
metabolizing replicating entity we call
alive to understand that and um so we
don't know um but of course um we uh we
may have some evidence from the spectrum
of some
exoplanets for a non-equilibrium
atmosphere so the exciting thing is that
we may from the James web telescope or
more likely from the big giant um
optical telescope being built by the Eur
Europeans in Chile um be able to get a
good enough Spectrum to actually see if
there's evidence of vegetation on some
exop plant around a nearby star so
you're saying simply by looking at the
light from a host star that passes
through the atmosphere of a transiting
Planet take to take the Spectrum and see
what molecules that exoplanet happens to
have in its atmosphere this is this is
being done already one of my colleagues
did this for JN Planet but may be
possible to do this um and um uh this is
another reason why I think um probes at
the outer planets are important because
um you know Enceladus which is a moon of
Saturn with ice and water underneath and
Europa
Europa um their probes on their way to
to to to Jupiter one soon on the way to
Saturn and um I think those are very
important experiment because if they uh
detected in the spray that's coming out
of the vents in the ice organic
molecules which indicated that there was
something swimming down there uh that
would be uh fantastic and that would be
such an important Discovery because it
would tell us that life had originated
um twice within one solar system
therefore it couldn't be a rare accident
and it would immediately tell us that
life existed in a billion places in our
galaxy in one PL system and there are
billions of PL system so you didn't
mention Mars presumably because we could
contaminate each other through yes yeah
thanks for mentioning that provisor the
reason I think we got to go that far is
that um material can go between Mars and
the Earth so if we found evidence of of
life on on Mars um then it could be that
we are all martians and our ancestors
Came From Mars um so that's why why it
is more compelling if it's found in the
outer solar system so uh simple life um
I think we will have some evidence on in
the next 10 20 years but then of course
the question is um uh um there are all
these hurdles and bottlenecks between
simple life and the complex biosphere of
which we're a part yeah and we don't
know the probability of those um but um
then again I mean um you know if if
you're if you're on a on a plane or
something and you've got next door a
neighbor if you don't want them to talk
to you you say you're a mathematician if
you want to talk to them you say you're
an astronomer but but then the first
question they ask is are we alone this
and it's the most fascinating question
so I think it's worth looking very hard
and uh I should say I'm a bit involved
because um Yori Milner who's a um a
Russian American billionaire is putting
money1 million doar a year into
improving the searches for
extraterrestrial intelligence and life
and I chair his Advisory board so I'm
I'm very Pro this as an exercise
although um I I'm not betting very much
on success because anything out there
could be very very different from
anything we imagine it may not be
organic at all and the reason I say that
is that um our Earth has taken um about
four billion years to evolve uh from
basic chemistry through the life that we
are part of uh but um our son is less
than halfway through his life and so we
could be near the beginning and the end
of the emergence of complexity and of
course there are other Earths around
other stars that could have had a
billionaire Head Start if they're around
St and so um some of them may have
evolved so they've got far beyond our
stage and then we have to ask what will
that be like and um I think one guess
that I would make and I've written about
this and I think it's a common view is
that um um there be a transition to some
kind of electronic life um which is um
perhaps able to process information more
efficiently than we can um and so ouro
progeny will be sort of electronic and
if they're electronic then of course
they'll be uh um near Immortal they
wouldn't be daunted by very long voyages
um they may prefer zero g they may not
want to be on a on a planet um and uh
and they may also and I think is
important points they may also be sort
of contemplative they may be just out
there thinking Deep Thoughts the reason
is that we have evolved by Darwin in
selection which favors um in aggression
sure um as well as intelligence whereas
um these entities will be designed
by designed what I call secular and to
design the machines will Design better
ones Etc and there's no particular
reason why they should be aggressive and
so um this I think is my answer to the
family paradox paradox argument that if
there are aliens out there why haven't
they come and eaten us or something
already um the argument is that if they
get very Advanced um they're probably
electronic and then may not be
expansionist at all so there may be a
lot out there yeah or it could also be
that they're just not interested in us
because we are just so unsophisticated
we're such a early stage of the process
I quickly interject though you know it
is also the case in darwinian studies
that a certain degree of cooperation
together with aggressiveness the sort of
tit forat strategy when it comes to
building social groups is actually
pretty potent so it's not purely
aggressive but yes we certainly see the
aggressive tendencies Tendencies
certainly um coming out in a significant
way um but when it comes to intelligent
life in the cosmos you rightly say we
just don't really understand the the
bottlenecks that that may um happen and
root do you have any feel for that I
mean could it be that life is plentiful
but intelligent life is pretty singular
um I think so I think Stephen J G
thought that um and but I think we we
just we just don't know um what the
bottlenecks are um but but it is worth a
look obviously although um I don't think
anyone could uh set reliable odds yeah
best but but I think it's
worth a sort of modest investment so but
you do think it would be among the
greatest achievements or revolutions or
changes in our perspective if we did
find other life or intelligent life out
there are I think most people think that
I know so here's my question on that
yeah I I I that's my gut feeling too but
then when I think about it a little bit
more as I've mentioned mentioned in
other conversations so some of our
audience may be familiar with this point
of view I then begin to wonder about it
and the reason I wonder about it is
there are so many civilizations on our
planet that we could be studying and we
could investigate but we don't because
we're just not that interested so when
we find other intelligent life isn't
there a chance at least that we'll be
excited for a week and then we'll kind
of shrug our shoulders and say okay
there's other life out they were not
alone fantastic but then we're just not
that interested to pursue their culture
their history their civilization and it
won't really have the kind of impact
that we all think it should or would
well you say we I mean obviously we're
only going to get crude evidence um and
willon be details but um uh although um
some people may not be interested at all
in what happens in other parts of the
world um uh lots of kids are more
fascinated by dinosaurs than anything
else yeah then it's nothing could be
more irrelevant to their lives and so uh
I think you know anyone who was
fascinated by dinosaurs would be surely
fascinated by some kind of monsters that
are
extraterrestrial and or maybe electronic
we don't know or some strange artifact
so I think everyone would accept would
make the universe much more interesting
yeah no I think so I just really wonder
what the long-term impact would be I
mean I hope that our intuition is
correct but I just don't know but look
also then takes us to the the issue of
space exploration I mean the James web
Space Telescope you point out it's going
to examine Spectra from atmospheres of
exoplanets we now know of more than what
something like 5,000 exoplanets that
number is going to grow we'll learn
about whether there biomarkers in those
atmospheres and so forth I mean
ultimately you know we want to go out as
opposed to just look out into space and
of course there are two ways way of
going about that you can have missions
that have human beings and there's
something interesting and exciting human
beings the final frontier all of that
but you can also have space exploration
by robots and those robots are going to
get every better over time yeah there's
definitely an argument in in the
community about how to balance these two
where do you come down on on that
question um well well I mean I think if
you want to actually do things make
discoveries um or assemble structures in
space and all that then clearly the
robots win hands down yeah even now um
if we think of the the robots crawling
around on on Mars um they can now the
second one perseverance can find his way
around obstacles in a way that Curiosity
appear one couldn't and the next one
will be able to do the geology and
decide where to dig and so and they they
can um go um to Jupiter without much
more difficulty
whereas sending people to Mars as you
know is amazingly difficult especially
if you want to bring them back so
expensive hugely expensive hugely
expensive um and uh and I think so so my
my take on this is very definitely if if
I was an American um I wouldn't want to
spend any taxpayers money on human space
flights um uh because the robots can do
so much more more cheaply um on the
other hand um uh I I think um uh if the
billionaires want to uh um send people
into space then I would cheer them on
that's that's great and the reason for
for this it's not it's not just that the
robots are more useful and V more V
cheaper it's that if if Nasa uses public
money to send people into space it's got
to be very risk averse yeah look at the
shuttle it failed twice in 135 launches
and that was barely that's not
acceptable at all right that's right and
you could never make a trip to Mars let
alone while the return trip 98% safe you
know and so I think if if the American
public was paying they'd be insisting on
further delays Etc um but we know very
well that there are people who would go
to Mars um even if there was less than
50% chance of coming back in fact ellon
mus says he wants to die on Mars but not
on impact and good luck to him he's 52
now so in 40 he could do this would you
go would you would you go um I think I'm
bit too old already but but you know I I
think what what a way to go I I think
lots of people would would would want to
go um yeah but obviously if you're
prepared to take the risk um and see it
as a extreme sport as it were um then I
think it's much cheaper and and um and
so I think private sponsorships you were
done but uh obviously it's got to L the
kind of people prepared to accept the
high risk yeah
we can share them on yeah now you know
I've had some conversations with folks
involved in these missions and they like
to point out that while it will take you
know a robot months and months and
months to clear a speck of dust from a
lens if you have a human being they can
just brush it off in two seconds but of
course I mean obviously isn't the answer
to that we're GNA get better I mean with
AI systems and robot it's going to be
clearly it's G to be point that will
challenge the capacities of a human
being yeah yeah yes so I think for
practical things and for exploring um
and um assembling big lightweight
structures for solar energy and
telescopes on the back side of the moon
all these things can be assembled by by
robots they don't need don't need people
um and uh and also the um I mentioned
musk and of course the uh the new rocket
which can um Carry up P of 100 tons and
could incident launched the James web
with the mirror in one piece much more
cheaply um that's going to make it
possible to assemble big structures up
in space But there again it doesn't need
people to go and um if if we send people
in this space then it's better if there
are people who are prepared to accept a
higher risk than the American public is
prepared to accept when it's supporting
them yeah and it seems like a very good
partnership even if that is more
metaphoric than literal I mean if you
have these billionaires who are these
you know space enthusiasts who are
willing to put in the money and the
effort and ultimately who knows maybe it
will reap the reward of you know space
tourism if that
succeeds let them let them go for it I
mean that's great you know and and and
allow the government to do what the
government does best which is a safer
more systematic approach which doesn't
have to bear the burden of what happens
when there's a catastrophe which of
course shuts down the whole system
immediately that's right um so so so
given that I'm wondering if we can turn
in the last part of our conversation to
not just the threats that you know human
space flight can pose to you know the
humans undertaking it but the threats
that we as a species face from our own
undertakings or some that are not ones
that are necessarily under our control
you've written a lot about the
existential dilemma that we human beings
face um yes
so what what do you consider to be the
big threats and then with that let's
just talk about what science can do
about it yes yes well as an averment
it's all in this book which I highly
recommend is a uh it came out last year
um but uh to answer your question I
think there's two classes of of concerns
there's the effects that we are as a
species causing
collectively because they're more of us
more demanding of resources and this is
leading to climate change loss of
biodiversity and all these slowly
emerging threats and then the second
kind is the
um threat of some sudden disaster caused
by ful new
technologies um and of course we've had
possib of nuclear war for a long time
but now we have bio and cyber uh which
can be um used by um small group or a
single person and where that's a huge
difference right there right I mean
absolutely yes because new nuclear
weapons can't be built without
conspicous facilities so and
verification and yeah and and monitoring
works for those but uh unless we're
going to give up privacy and have
intrusive surveillance of everyone or at
least everyone who knows enough biology
to build a bioweapon then um we are
going to have to worry about um error or
Terror leading to something biological
and as we know from the from coid 19
these things can spread globally um and
of course um um it's possible to as you
know engineer a um a virus far more
veent and transmissible than natural
ones um with a very high fatality rate
Etc so that's that's something and also
of course um cyber attacks um uh in fact
in my book I quote 10 years ago there
was a report from the American defense
department about um uh what could be
done by a state level Cyber attack on
the electricity Grid in the US and shut
things down scary yeah you get disorder
um soal breakdown within a few days Etc
um and it says in this report this would
Merit a nuclear
response now 10 year 10 years later it
doesn't need a state level probably a
few individuals where AI could do the
same sort of thing and so these are
really worrying and so I think it's
quite right that um AI in general um is
um higher on the agenda how to regulate
it and it's very hard to regulate it
because um the key player
um are
multinational corporations uh and just
as it's hard they can escape paying
proper tax and they can escape
regulations in the same way probably so
so it's very hard to regulate them um
and we've got but we've got to try um
and uh there are lots of discussions
about how we can regulate the uh the use
of um the techniques that can create
viruses Etc but um just as we can't
can't control the um the drug laws or
the tax laws when small numbers of
people are involved I do worry and I
don't worry about the um super intive
machines killing us all this is one
scenario um that's not impossible but
but what I do worry about is being
over-dependent on these systems so that
um if uh if they go wrong there some
sort of bug or some
intentional attack on them uh we can't
cure them and we're so dependent that uh
um Society just breaks down there no
electricity Etc um we we just may not be
able to to recover and so um we'll have
a very bumpy ride through the century if
we can't somehow ensure that uh um
individuals Bad actors uh can't be too
much impowered what do you think about
the argument though that has been made C
certainly by some of the leading AI
people that you know regulation sure
within within reason but this idea that
somehow we should have a moratorium or
sort of stop work in the direction of AI
in the end the argument goes that that
may in fact just benefit the Bad actors
because if you have a moratorium that's
stated the very people that will abide
by it are typically the good guys people
who won't bu buy it are the Bad actors
and so the way to make things worse is
to slow down in that sense and perhaps a
way to make things better is to assume
that there are more good actors than bad
there are smarter individuals on the
good side than the bad and just develop
AI both as a powerful tool for good but
as a powerful tool for rooting out evil
and so perhaps AI is our most powerful
means for trying to contain the very
things that we're afraid of oh what's
your view on that well I think you've
missed out what is the the best option
um we should encourage the research but
just like in
drugs when a research gives a new drug
it's not relased on the market straight
away there's lots of clinical trials and
testing and that didn't happen for chat
gbt and things like that they left us to
do testing and so uh one doesn't want to
discourage the research yeah it would be
best actually if the research was done
in sort of international Labs rather
than private companies but you don't to
discourage that but what you do want to
do is to make sure that nothing is
released or um no uh program is
implemented until it's being properly
tested and would you restrict for
instance access to gpus and things of
that sort much the way we restrict
access to you know FIS material so that
you know we can contain the building of
those sorts of weapons um well I'm not
sure where I draw the line but I think
obviously You' got have some
restrictions but but I think um there
needs to be some some kind of
international Authority and indeed um um
I think there's an agreement that there
should be some kind of entity like the
um nuclear regulatory agency something
of that sort yeah something like that um
but of course the the trouble is that um
these could be done in a small scale way
so you can't regulate everything but but
I think there's got to be some gap
between developing something and
releasing it on the market or using it
so but what about the difference that we
made reference to at the outset though
because now you don't need some big
centrifuge you don't need big equipment
you can have individuals who gain access
to tools that may have been tested and
when used in a productive way are
incredibly powerful and useful but how
do you leas things when it's individuals
or small groups of individuals that can
unleash these kind of forces that's why
it's harder than it was in the case of
nuclear yeah and I think we uh we've got
to accept intrusive
surveillance we got to give how far
would you go on that I mean well I mean
we we're used to CCTV cameras I think
anyone with the capability to do this
sort of thing has got to accept that
they will be subject to surveillance so
they could not clandestinely do this
sort of thing really really big brother
in in the home watching what you're
doing yes because the stakes are so high
we don't want but but you know the three
things we'd like to preserve uh Freedom
security and privacy yeah and the
tension we can't have all three if you
want to avoid these these um disaster
from Bad actors and I think
realistically it's a um it's privacy is
going to have to go so yeah yeah and so
when you Envision the world like 10 or
even fewer years from now do you think
it really will perhaps be like that that
there will be surveillance in the home
or you know maybe that's you know too
literal but surveillance on your
computer monitoring what's happening on
your electronic devices yes there may be
and and I'd be quite happy to accept
that and do you think that you are alone
in that or a minority or or would you be
unhappy about that well it's interesting
that you ask because I am pretty open
because I don't feel like I do anything
that feels deeply confidential however
you know I do have people in my life I
won't name names my wife who um you know
just don't like this idea of of anybody
being able to see what they are doing
not because they're doing something
nefarious or wrong it's just privacy is
so vital and sacran that they're just
not willing to give give that up yeah
yeah yes so you know it is a it's a it's
a difficult question they to accept it
or go low Tech low Tech and not use
computers right I mean certainly that
would be the option I guess if these
kinds of surveillance Vehicles were put
into place that you would just remove
yourself from from the electronic grid I
guess which is you know in the old days
people would just go off to a a mountain
Virginia or or someplace to hide away
but now I guess you just hide away by
disconnecting yeah I mean I'm not saying
that I'm not saying I like this scenario
but I think honestly um given um that's
the uh the risk of some catastrophe
which spreads
globally um could be the outcome of some
bad actor acting almost solo then I
think we've got to accept that the
Lesser evil is to give up some privacy
yeah now now given all that I mean you
certainly have spent a significant
amount of uh energy and well spent
energy on trying to educate the public
on the very kinds of ideas that we've
been speaking about you know in our
conversation now I certainly have have
done that too what do you see as the
realistic role of scientists in helping
to shape a future that perhaps is nicer
than the one that we're painting right
now well I think it's clear they've got
to um uh explore all the
scenarios um so that we can be as well
prepared and minimize the risks and of
course um there are many ways we can do
to make things things safer we've
learned some lessons from coid and we've
learned that uh there's a trade up
between resilience and efficiency and
it's maybe more efficient to have long
Supply chains and spanning the world but
it's not that's a it's not resilient Etc
so we've learned lots of things and and
um I think scientist can help to make
things more resilient and obviously do
things like like making better vaccines
um but I think um we've we've got to um
also accept that if scientists discover
something which uh has potential severe
downsides um they they can't deal with
it themselves but they've got to ensure
that the authorities are fully aware of
it uh and it goes goes back to um
well it's in their minds because of the
recent op oppenheim movie you know the
piles and frish and then Einstein and
others they they warn the politicians
that a nuclear weapon was a possibility
um and uh and also um they uh the people
who helped to make the bomb when they
returned to civilian life they uh didn't
isolate themselves from a concern to do
all they could to uh ensure that it
wasn't used so they have a special
um responsibility but on the other hand
um they uh can't expect to decide things
because the ethics of how things are
used is an ethical question when
scientists don't have uh any specially
insightful ethical views and so I think
there's a issue that there's some cases
when the scientists have a special
obligation and
other context where um it's an ethical
decision where uh everyone should have
the right to an equal say but the the
case of of nuclear weaponry I wonder if
the following gives you particular pause
or not so you're right there were some
scientists who left that endeavor and
did try to do things that would make the
world safer now that these nuclear
weapons were part of the reality that we
had to deal with but at the same time
there's this you know this very powerful
quote of Freeman Dyson which I won't get
correct but it was something like the
power to lift a million tons of rock
into the air it was intoxicating and we
were swept Along by the power that we
were
unleashing because clearly after we had
the atomic bomb you know my quote is
over I'm now speaking as me you know to
go forward to go even beyond that and
build you know the hydrogen bomb yet
more powerful bomb you know Edward
Teller and so forth so we scientists can
certainly get swept up in the in the the
Allure of Discovery and the power of
being able to control the forces of the
universe so you know is is that a scary
side to you of the scientific scary
somehow to be restrain but if we stick
to the nuclear context uh
um as you know the um the HB was a
controversial matter and some some
wouldn't join in um but but if you think
of those who worked at lot Alamos um
then rotblat was the only one who
resigned when it was clear that Hitler
wasn't going to get a bomb yeah but all
those and you know I'm old enough to
have met in their later years people
like piles and Hans beta and all these
people and um they uh felt they had an
obligation to do all they could to
harness the pows they had helped unleash
um and uh they weren't they weren't like
you like you say tella maybe a bit like
that but I think uh they weren't all
like like that right and um just as I I
think um there may be some medical
people who
would feel it's important to have some
special techniques that they know about
most would be important they think it
important to ensure that any medical
advance that makes the world safer or
healthier is implemented
widely so they should influence the
politicians and of course um this is
true for climate scientists for instance
um climate scientists need to ensure
that the politicians and the public know
the um
dangers that we're causing ourselves by
not controlling CO2 emissions and all
that that's familiar um and the problem
there is that the the threat is not not
immediate it's long term so we're like
the uh um the frog in the warming tank
of water which doesn't escape
doesn't until it's too late to do so
we're in that situation and in that
context the problem my view is that um
politicians have to be convinced of
public cares they won't listen to expert
advisors um except in an emergency they
did in the case of coid to some extent
but but they won't if if they don't feel
the gain votes and that's why um I think
it's very important that we should um uh
uh uh hope that there will be some
charismatic influences
um you know if Carl Sean was one um you
know he would um
um generate huge inspiration among a
wide public and um by by his eloquence
and determination um but but in fact in
my book I I mentioned of rather
desperate quartet who've done this for
climate change um Pope Francis with his
encyclical our secular Pope David atenor
with all his programs about uh life on
Earth and biodiversity um Bill Gates
great deal of sense about
technology yeah yeah yes those four
different from each other they've
collectively I think um raised these
issues on the public agender so the
public cares and even change the
rhetoric of business though not enough
the actual actions of business so that's
where politicians um need to be
influenced um and the experts themselves
may not be eloquent enough or infers
enough but uh if they can somehow um
have as intermediaries charismatic
individuals um and think back to racial
Caston and all
that then that's very important and so I
think if one is involved in science
which has some uh major impacts on
global safety Etc then one has an
obligation to do what one can to try and
uh enlist the support of these
individuals
yeah and as you say I think part of the
main charge is not necessarily to make
the general public expert on on the
issues but to make it clear that these
are vital issues that the general public
needs to care about yes and once once
that movement is underfoot then you can
have impact on actual decision making
yes and of course there might be a
variety of possible actions and then
decid between those then the public as a
whole has to be consulted yes and um and
look you hope that we do a good enough
job so that there's a sensible enough
level of discourse and and
thoughtfulness that goes into the
positions that people take because it
can make a huge huge difference as we
have seen in the world I wanted to
finish up Martin just with a returning
to some of the science just for a final
quick round of
questions when you look you know imagine
we go a hundred years into the future
it's unlikely that I'll be here there's
a chance that you'll be here but you
know there's a you know there are you
know realities that we all face but I
mean I think I get the feeling that you
and I are both pretty optimistic about
you know where where science is going
and so I just want to get your sense
hundred years from now do you think
we'll know what the dark matter
is
um I think
quite quite likely I think we will yes
although uh it may it may be slow
because um the simple things have been
discovered and it's more effort to go to
high endes so so I wouldn't bet on it
but we'll understand more about his
properties because we can indirectly
infer his properties whether it really
is collisionless or or not from studying
galaxies and all that um and of course
we've got to remember that astronomy is
quite useful in it it allows us to study
conditions far more extreme in terms of
energy or density temperature than we
can produce in the lab yeah now yeah go
ahead I'm sorry no no so in that case um
I think it we'll have a deeper
understanding I would say sure and um we
didn't spend a whole lot of time talking
about Dark Energy directly we did talk
about the accelerated expansion of space
which is being We Believe driven by the
dark energy some 70% of the energy
budget of the cosmos when it comes to
Dark Energy we don't know what that is
either do you think it's likely that a
hundred years from now we'll know what
the dark energy is um well again I mean
I I defer to you because you know far
more about this than me but I think um
uh um it's got to be something latent in
empty space yeah and to do with a sort
of granularity of empty space on a scale
of 10us 33 cm when what we think of a in
our three-dimensional space is a wound
up origami in all the extra dimensions
and all that and so I think we won't
understand um Dark Energy until we have
that kind of theory yeah I I agree with
that and look you know it could well be
that the dark energy like dark matter
I'm convinced of dark energy could be a
placeholder for some unknown quality
that plays the same role of giving rise
to this repulsive push but the nature of
it might be different from what we think
today so that one I consider to be a
much more difficult question than the
question of Dark Matter yes what about
do you think we'll have a real credible
if we had this conversation a hundred
years from now would we have a credible
understanding of the creation event
itself when we talk about the Big Bang
it's really the aftermath of some kind
of event that got everything going will
we be able to go back to the beginning
itself
well I mean maybe not of course the
question is is there really a beginning
or is it one metaphor is that's like
asking can we go North to the North Pole
can we go back before the beginning so
we don't know but um as I say I will
hope we will have um a better
understanding of the extreme physics of
the first tiny tiny fraction of a second
which may tell us um why the universe
has agre does the small Bion and things
of that kind and why this dark matter
and maybe why this dark energy so we may
have a an all embracing theory that
accounts for all these things um but
again I wouldn't count on it but um yeah
um and of course um if you ask me about
biology then how well will we understand
the brain by that stage yeah no it's uh
and and as we were saying before since
everything we learn about the universe
is processed through the brain the brain
itself simply may not have the power to
answer these questions but we can remain
optimistic and hope that we'll at least
make progress toward the answers even if
we don't have the definitive
conclusions well Martin it's been a
fascinating conversation thank you so
much for joining us and you know let's
just hope that the best possible outcome
on the future of humanity is what is in
store for us and um but we can't be
complacent as you say we need to really
as scientists try to spread as much much
information not disinformation so that
the public really has some vested
interest and understanding in these
vital issues that can have an impact on
on where things go from here so again
thank you so much for joining us yes and
do a great job on this so
congratulations on what you're doing oh
well thank you I of course appreciate
that enormously and I hope that you will
come back to join us live in New York
we're now doing Live Events finally
after the pandemic has finally passed so
we look forward to hosting you in New
York City in the not too distant future
for a live inperson conversation but
thanks for joining for this digital
conversation it really has been
fascinating thank you very much thank
you all right so that's the end of our
conversation here again I just W to
leave with a quick summary which of
course you know we started this
conversation on this idea that has the
James web Space Telescope somehow
undermined our confidence in our
understanding of of cosmology some
articles seem to suggest that it has but
I certainly don't feel that way and I
think the majority of the community
including sir Martin Ree don't feel that
way either we have a really deep and
solid understanding of part of
cosmological History going back to say I
don't know a microsecond after the
beginning which is amazing and again as
we've seen we can make predictions about
heat left over from The Big Bang the
cosmic microwave background radi a we
can make predictions using equations and
then we can compare those predictions
with observations as we showed in one of
our graphs earlier on and holy smokes
the agreement between the theory the
mathematics and the observation is just
so spectacular that clearly we've got a
deep understanding we can make
predictions about the abundances of
Light Elements hydrogen helium lithium
dyum and we can make comparisons between
the predictions and our observations and
again an incredible agreement between
the two so cosmology is really under you
know it's it's a solid understanding of
the world there are things in our
cosmological theory that we've yet to
fully understand we do not yet know what
the dark matter is made of we do not yet
know what the dark energy is we do not
yet know what really started the
expansion in the first place it could
have been this inflationary cosmology
but there are other ideas that are now
on the table and that's that's exciting
right that doesn't undermine our
confidence it allows us to follow the
very same Rhythm that science has always
followed which is the deeper you
understand the world the more refined
the questions that you can subsequently
ask and investigate and of course that's
what we're doing and that's what we're
doing with the James web based telescope
and look don't get me wrong if our
understanding of cosmology ultimately is
overturned thrilling that would be
wonderful but we're nowhere near
anything like that today that would be
hugely exciting that's the kind of thing
that we live for but just so that it's
clear where we are at the moment our
theory of cosmology is thriving it is
healthy it is vibrant and we now just
need to push forward to answer yet more
deep questions that our understanding
has allowed us to ask and to pursue so
my thanks today to Sir Martin Reese for
joining us in this this conversation
that walked through our understanding of
cosmology and then went on to discuss
what we're going to do to go forward
both from the standpoint of space
exploration and of course the need to
protect our own future as a living
species on this planet and let's just
hope that some of the ideas and lessons
and insights that sir Martin Ree has
shared with us will actually guide what
we as a species do in the future so
assuming that we continue to be here in
the following weeks we will continue to
give the world these kinds of
conversations our upcoming discussions
we're GNA have one with Juan mald Desa
that some of you may know got derailed
by some technical issues with our stream
we're going to I believe do that
conversation on November 17
we'll then have a conversation with
Steven Wolfram and we got a variety of
other conversations that will follow
those we will also begin to roll out our
live conversations from the world
Science Festival science in September
series that we held in New York City in
September really fascinating
conversations that span the gamut
cosmology quantum mechanics String
Theory Ai and so forth so look for those
programs as we make them available if
you're not already a subscriber to this
Channel please subscribe so that you can
be alerted when our new programs come on
and you can also join the world science
festival's newsletter where you'll also
get alerts when new programs are coming
out all right that's all for today from
World science fesal headquarters here in
New York City I am Brian Green thanks
for joining
[Music]
us
oh